arrghh
next Columbia University professor John
McWhorter examines how word meanings
have changed over time this program
contains language that some may find
offensive
welcome to Manhattan library my name is
Erica Parker I'm a librarian here at Mid
Manhattan before we get started out of
respect for the speaker and your fellow
audience members I'd like you to please
silence all electronic devices at this
time thank you for joining us for an
author talks with John McWhorter on its
book words on the move why English won't
and can't sit still like literally
there's a language shift
constantly did you know the word clue
derives from clue a Middle English word
meaning ball of yarn in Greek myths area
and ball of thread leads the hero
Theseus through the labyrinth now it
makes sense
countless other words have changed this
way taking on new meanings or new shades
of meanings in the age of memes and
texting lol FW MSW TS of you etc
language continues to shift but as John
McWhorter explains this shouldn't scare
us too might be explains how the English
language is evolving before our eyes and
argues why we should embrace this change
not fight it John McWhorter is an
associate professor of English and
comparative literature at Columbia
University he is the author of more than
15 books including the language hooks
and the power of Babel he's currently
writing his 20th book please get a warm
welcome to John recorder
[Applause]
I'm thanks everybody I want to talk to
you for not too long about a new way of
hearing language and I think it's
important because I think linguists have
failed to explain the realities of how
language change works and what language
really is and we're often a little
impatient you don't understand why
everybody sees it differently than we do
but really there's a lot in common
between languages and natural district
the way biologists have taught us to see
flora and fauna you'd never know it from
the way language is taught in the school
system you'd never know it from even
taking just one or two linguistics
classes if certain things aren't really
hit on the head so I want to give you a
new way of looking at language that will
feel good all of this just makes it so
if you walk down the street
feeling better about what you hear and
possibly feeling better about your own
speech and what it comes down to is this
it's about the fact that language is
inherently changeable language changes
is not that it might change it always
will change it must change now if you
ask somebody whether they think language
to change I don't think anybody would
say no but I think we tend to think that
what language changes is first of all
that you need new words for new things I
think anybody would accept that you
would assume that a lot of those words
probably are going to come from foreign
languages and that is something you
might process as exciting and then we
all know that flying changes so why
inves changes language change is much
more profound than that and so see if
this works
okay there we go so there's what we know
and here's what you don't learn so we'll
always need new words for new things
that's true
but what we're not taught is that
language changes as inevitably as cloud
patterns change the analogy is with
looking up in the sky and seeing the
clouds today and then how you would feel
if you looked up tomorrow and saw the
clouds in the same place that would be
utterly bizarre nobody would expect it
it's the same thing with language change
why was change has to change the way
cloud pattern have to change clouds have
changed by wind language is changed
because every generation slightly miss
years or reinterpret what the last
generation said that's never not
happened and it always will or words
will come in from foreign languages yeah
that's true but if you took a group of
people and for some reason put them in a
cave and somehow they could live in the
cave with food and everything that they
needed but they were in the cave and
there was no cultural change there was
no contact with anybody else
and asking for people somehow managed to
reproduce and lid in the cave for 2,000
years
when those people came out of the cave
they would be speaking a whole new
language not because anything new was
invented not because they had met
anybody else and it wouldn't be just the
slang they wouldn't understand the
people who had gone into the cave that's
because it's inherent to language to
change that what language changes or we
know that slang and idioms will change
yeah but hard to see that a dictionary
the dictionary is a wonderful thing but
a dictionary page is like a Polaroid
snapshot and that's really all with it
it can be a beautiful Polaroid snapshot
but if you have a Polaroid of somebody
at 40 and then 10 years later you
encounter that person and you show them
the picture of themselves at 40 you
don't think that the way they were at 40
is somehow the way they really are and
that any change
since then is somehow wrong or peculiar
people change languages are the same way
language changes in basically five ways
that's not true
but four words on the move I have kind
of fashioned it into five easy to
remember way and one of them is
something that tonight I'm going to call
creeping implications words changed by a
creeping implication and what I mean by
that is that at any point in time a word
has different resonances surrounding it
there's the quote unquote dictionary
definition and then there are other
things that that word makes you think of
as time goes by what everybody thinks of
the word is meaning moves into including
those resonances such that after a while
the words meaning has changed and after
a while while the word meaning is
unrecognizable that is something that
happens to almost every word in any
language the words that don't change
like an or in or words for things like
father and brother those are the
exceptions that's just a boring little
collection of 100 or 200 words most
words are always moving along so for
example silly first meant blessed
audition first met you're hearing it has
nothing to do with being up on stage of
trying out for something lewd first
men's and the italic ization is messed
up there I apologize unlearn it you can
imagine how unlearning might morph into
meaning sexually improper but originally
movement unlearning yes I know that if
you read salsa Mary first men short it
gradually came to mean jolly because
that which is short is often Pleasant
have been bit by bit meet first men tall
food lows was the word for bread wort
which we now associate with health food
stores that was the word for vegetable
vegetable came in later Apple first met
fruit so for example let's say that
you're blessed
and we imagine what that word means now
if you're blessed
then there's reason to think that you're
innocent and so a word that first means
blessed might many generations later
mean that you're innocent something with
innocent is probably harmless
it follows and that was a resonance that
was surrounding the word and next thing
you knew a word that originally meant
blessed meant harmless that's far enough
if something's harmless it's probably
weak and so the word came to mean weak
you can see this happening century by
century if you're weak one way you might
be weak is mentally you might be not
only physically weak but you might be
kind of slow not very bright and so
after a while that word that meant
blessed men did if you're dim one of the
ways you might manifest it is that
you're kind of goofy and gradually and
that meaning came in such that blessed
met goofy originally the word meant
happy and so a word that started out
meaning happy became blessed became
innocent became harmless became weak
became slow became goofy all of that was
a single word salic and this is the
thing that's normal
that's what words do almost every word
in your mouth is doing that we can't
feel it within our lifetimes but that's
how language change works so this that's
implication that's not just that silly
is interesting or almost any word that
you're using has that kind of history it
gives you a sense of why Shakespeare can
be difficult to hear in real time if you
haven't read it first and this is a
controversial topic and I know many
people say that with Shakespeare it's
just a matter of poetry or that it has
to be performed really well or that it's
better when the person has a British
accent but I think all of us know that
still is all of those claims are in
place Shakespeare if you haven't read it
something to read it but in real time
they were doing King Lear right here and
you hadn't read it it's tough you get
tired after about 20 minutes and
somebody tells you that you're not going
it's not only the poetry it's that words
meanings change and Shakespeare lived a
long time ago and so a lot of words that
we hear sound like English because they
are but the words don't mean what they
mean to us because so much time has gone
by so for example Edmund said he's
defending himself against charges why
faster where for bass when my dimensions
are as well compact compact Assad in
itself we can kind of let that go my
mind is generous and my shape is true as
honest Madam's issue my mind is generous
now why generous people are making fun
of him and he's objecting that he's free
with his good is not impossible but it's
odd it's a little bump as you're
listening to the actor saying this and
he keeps going he's not going to stop
and explaining and you can't act your
way through then my mind is generous we
don't usually talk about a generous
brain if it's a wad and so that happens
if that happens about three times a page
there goes too fatigued generous when
Shakespeare wrote it meant Noble notice
how all of a sudden that makes sense
he's talking about how he is as Noble as
anyone else if you're Noble then
especially back then part of being a
noble involved being magnanimous with
your folk as a result after a while
generous came to mean magnanimous and
you needed a new word for noble and it
was actually Noble and so that's why
Shakespeare is hard this point there's
cushion because I know how angry some
people get at the idea that Shakespeare
might be get ready for it changed
there's a growing movement especially
over the past 20 years not to translate
Shakespeare wouldn't be necessary but to
adjust Shakespeare especially where the
words are such that we can no longer
understand what he meant when hearing it
live and haven't read
so for example and they death again
besides this Duncan has borne his
faculties so meek at faculties what does
it mean well you don't have time because
the person is going to keep going so
besides this Duncan hath borne his
faculties so me that's been so clear and
his great office clear was I'm not clear
in my office I'm sitting in a chair
nobody would say my John you're looking
clear ah but it's a play and he keeps
going that his virtues will plead like
angels trumpet-tongued against the deep
and you're happy now because that's
poetic like angels trumpet-tongued
against the deep damnation of his
taking-off taking off where is he going
we think of taking off as flying what
does it mean but he keeps going that's
hard now you can read the footnotes but
let's face it we're busy life is hard
and after a while especially after you
have kids you don't have time to read it
and so you're watching it live well
suppose you change that to the things
that it means so besides this Duncan
hath born Authority so nice even scams
his faculties Authority has born his
authority so meek has been not clear in
his great office because we can't know
what that means so pure in his great
office the idea being that he keeps his
hands clean but his virtues will plead
like angels trumpet-tongued against the
deep damnation not its taking off of his
knocking fault that's what it meant it
had a kind of a slimy flavor well so
does knocking off for us so the issue is
that words meanings change so what this
means is it's no such thing as a
community of speakers using a word wrong
we hear it that way we think well lately
people are using such-and-such to mean
this but it's supposed to mean that but
we understand that its inherent to a
word for its meaning to change if we
understand that a word isn't something
that is it's something going on that's
the way language has always been then it
means that if a representative number of
people
are using a word a certain meaning then
the meaning has changed as would
inevitably have been the case that's not
odd it's just that that evidence of the
reality of language in your own life now
there's a reasonable objection which is
if a person can use a word anyway they
want then doesn't it interfere with
clarity but the answer is this it's
people not a person that uses a word in
a new way so meaning change is communal
no language has ever been recorded where
various people just went their own way
and start of having trouble
understanding one another that would be
a problem never happen and that's
because this is a communal matter so
words meanings change creeping
implications means that you can think of
yourself as speaking something that's
ever-changing and it becomes a sport to
wonder where the words meanings are
going to go because there are as various
choices as to how it's going to happen
but to wait for the words meanings to
state in the same place is unfortunate
because they're always going to keep
changing and so you always hear this
dissolution taking place when really
it's just language as it's always been
so first night second thing two phases
of English and these are types of words
and expressions that you never taught
about in school you never taught about
this as grammar but it's actually a
crucial part of what a language is on
linguists call it pragmatics which is an
unfortunate jargon term I'm going to
call because we think of pragmatics as
being about 18 different things so I'm
not going to say pragmatics ever again
we're going to call it the phases of
English and I've got this cute little
acronym here it's all about sexuality
acknowledgement counter expectation and
even the first letters of those things
spell face and so that's what we're
going to call it now what do I mean by
that well we have sexuality markers in
our language
where we have words that we use in ways
where we could barely say exactly what
they mean so for example really I got
tired of the way he was acting really I
just can't take it anymore
really it's been raining for so long
that I'm tired really now formally we
think that it means really in real
fashion but we don't pronounce it that
way which is one clue it's not really
it's really if you're a child and you
can't read yet you have to learn that
this word that really should be spelled
RI ll Y is real ly and what we use
really for is to indicate in an ongoing
way when we talk that we are sincere
it's a part of human conversation and
we're not doing it in a tidy sort of way
such that we do it once at the beginning
of something called paragraph and never
do it again it's something that we
constantly do almost the way somebody
might be cooling themselves and do the
same gesture over and over on the Donald
Trump's believe me is one of those
sexuality markers and so people will say
why does he say that it's because he
want to indicate his sexuality and he
has chosen that particular formula now
sexuality explained the literally
problem and so there are many people who
are very upset that literally is being
misused because it's supposed to mean by
the letter exactly and yet people seem
to be using it in figurative
constructions and so people say I'm
literally dying of thirst
and that's just wrong because it means
that you're using something to mean its
opposite both the factual and then
figuratively that really gets up
people's noses but it really doesn't
have to really believe me this is what
literally starts out meeting by the
letters and by the litter now that's
what it meant at a certain point
everybody who thought of it is meaning
only that it is now very very dead and
they died not knowing something that you
guys and women can all know which is
that literally was never going to stay
meaning just by the letter no word ever
stays still so the only question was
what was it going to come to me now one
thing that words do tend to do when they
have a meaning of intensifying is that
they become less intense and so you just
knew you could have put bets on it that
a word that meant by the letter was
eventually going to start meaning
something like really that was the way
it was going to week it you just knew
that was going to happen but once it
means really of course people are going
to use it to intensify their figurative
expressions because that's what we do
when we speak next thing you know just
as you might say I was really dying of
thirst and not mean it you could say I
was literally dying of thirst
you knew that was going to happen now
often it said I say it's my foot tangled
in this wire that this use of 'literally
is new and I can imagine how it must
feel that way there are many reasons why
it would feel new oh no this is on a
sentence if a fortunate man to be
introduced to such a party with fine
women at his arrival
it is literally to feed among the lilies
1769 and this is somebody who's writing
in a much more formal error so it's not
not new but why irritates people is
because of the idea that it's this word
that means its opposite and people think
well that can't be
I had actually seen a teacher
where somebody complains about literally
on their chest if they say the word
literally being used to mean
figuratively I stand against it but
how's it fast you can run fast but then
you can be fast asleep
you can sit fast stuck fast it means
both rapid and then the very opposite of
Breathitt does it ever bother you and if
you're aware of it now isn't it kind of
neat and then there are lots of words
like that somebody can bolt away you can
bolt the chair to the ground and you
know the world keeps spinning if you
feed a watermelon chances are that you
do not purchase some seeds and then put
them into the watermelons before you eat
it
you're taking the seeds out but then if
you're seeding a plot of land it would
be counterproductive to take the seeds
out of the ground you're putting them in
has that ever confuse you that's three
example and I think there's seven of
them up there
they're about seventy five of what are
called contra names in this language
contra name number roughly 56 is
literally and so to the sense that we
have probably rarely not known what a
person meant if a person said I was
literally freezing to death what they're
telling you implies that they didn't die
and so you aren't confused it means that
we've just got another continent contra
names are fun literally is there for fun
acknowledgement an awful lot of language
is a matter of looking into the person
you're speaking to his mind and
acknowledging their state of mind while
outlining your eyes now nobody puts it
that way but that's an awful lot of what
we mean by certain things such as
totally the way people below a certain
they use totally these things it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean in total fashion so
if someone says we're totally going to
get tickets for that Taylor Swift
concert they don't mean we're going to
get too
kids for the Taylor Swift concert in a
complete way that's not what it means
we're totally going to get tickets for
the Taylor Swift concert means it
doesn't really mean something it does
something it means we both know that
they're reasons why some people would
say that we shouldn't get those tickets
such as that maybe she's considered a
little bit XY or Z or were busy students
or something like that but we are going
to get the tickets if somebody says oh
he's totally going to call you it's not
he's going to call you in his
completeness is he's going to call you
even though some people have reason to
believe that he's not that's actually
what everybody's saying totally walking
down New York streets every day means by
total it's an acknowledgment of standing
conditions of which all are aware and
you don't get taught these things but
that's what it means so there are lots
of acknowledgement markers and this is a
modern language this is all language
here's some Chaucer so Emily says in the
night sale I am thou loosed that meant
no yet of thy company a made and I love
hunting and venerate she's saying you
know so today we hear you know as a kind
of a tick but Tulsa was putting it in a
very very long time ago
so if actuality and acknowledgement then
counter expectation is a major aspect of
how you actually communicate it doesn't
fit into our sense of what an adjective
or a spence's but it's very much grammar
so the reason that I put ABS there if I
may is because that things that you can
think of as profane as some sort of
degradation of language which are really
very sophisticated so for example you
might think that to append an adjective
with ass is just to be vulgar and that's
a big ass pop and you think what could
the person just say big pop it's because
they need something very specific
imagine a person looking out a window
and they see a squirrel and they say hey
I see a grass squirrel
that doesn't just mean I see a gray
squirrel and I'm a kind of a gutbucket
sort of person it has a more specific
meaning it means hey that squirrel is
grey rather than the black squirrels
that I expect because in some places I
forget which ones the squirrels are
black you would only say I saw a gray a
squirrel if you came from somewhere
where the squirrels were a different
color so what you mean is huh
the squirrel is gray is a gray a
squirrel we went to this long-ass opera
it means it was longer than you would
expect anything to be it was probably
vogner
for example that's what it means listen
to the way people use that ass because
they do all the time tomorrow and you'll
notice it's never just profanity it's
always that it's counter expectation
there are less pungent ways of
expressing the counter expectational but
I wanted to understand I'm talking about
language as we know it easy LOL much ink
has been spilled over laugh-out-loud as
it originally meant being used
constantly in texting in particular and
some of the rails into speech to make
sense but it's especially known in
texting now you can find any number of
accounts of lol that say that it's quote
unquote doesn't mean anything and that's
because it's one of these faiths words
so you can see this actual text exchange
so I like you I'm pretty sure everyone
else figured that out before you lol but
what does it mean I don't know just
assuming I'm sure if you did lol but I
guess I shouldn't assume why they
sprinkling that in there use it they
change that they caressed me again so it
won't cancel for a while lol lol and it
just seems so unsystematic you know what
that is think about how much we laugh
when we talk to each other
casual there's an awful lot of really
empty laughter that one does if you
don't giggle a little bit making little
jokes while you're talking to people
especially people you only know so well
your process as unfriendly it's an
unspoken part of being a normal human
being too
chuckle a little bit and to smile a
little bit when you're interacting with
people
lol is how texting has created that
exact same easing that laughter serves
to make it clear that everything is okay
we're always indicating that we really
mean things we're always looking into
other people's brains
we are always engaging the counter
expectations and we're always keeping
things easy LOL does that and so it's a
face markers just like our involuntary
easing laughter is when we talk so all
of those things and as you can imagine
they're long lists of sexuality
acknowledgement countering sensational
needs and markers and they're very much
as part of the language as using past
tense or pluralizing a noun non-standard
dialect is easy and so very often you
will hear some people who can speak
Standard English and then they also use
a different kind of speech among one
another yes I'm thinking in particular
of black Americans because we're in
America and it's often said well why
they talk like that why do they do that
why did I have to be different why does
yes
President Obama sound different when he
talks to the n-double-a-cp
and I've known many thoroughly
well-intentioned enlightened people who
actually heard the president as faith in
that they think well if he can talk one
way why would he talk to other that's
because non-standard dialect
going into it is another kind of easing
and it's something that probably every
second person in the world does to some
extent by switching to a different
language in situations or if not that
than a different dialect so it's very
much part of language and so once again
you have a way of hearing language in a
more positive way and so it can be one
thing to listen to all these literally
than you know the masses and actually
even lol's and think what is all this
trash why don't people sound like Edward
Gibbon but they never they never have
and all of these states markers have a
sophistication of their
so those are the big two then there are
three other aspects of how language
changes now there's a word for this that
linguists use it's called bruh
medicalization that sounds like a
disease and so that's the last time I'm
going to use that term but there's a
chapter about it and words on the move
we're going to call it where the little
bits come from because that's how I
actually think of it so for example can
yes you can do it can came from no
that's what it first meant that little
bit so you can say you can do this that
little couldn't that you can identify
that originally came from the verb to
know as it can e and cunning and coos
all of those words started out as being
two note words always change there once
wasn't over couse it meant could that's
normal ought is one of the oddest little
words it's kind of like you learn that
you have a tongue in your mouth and
suddenly it feels kind of odd except
this wet muscle but you're kind of stuck
with it odd is that way look at that
word look at how it fell think about how
to say it it's like a seal yell but
where did aunt come from it was the word
for ode you can hear it use that way in
Shakespeare thought meant owed you owed
something to somebody you ought them
next thing you know you ought to do
something Lee advert really first was
like which men body so what happened is
that what we think of as ordinary words
become pieces of grammar that just
basically managed the traffic between
words
so Richard the third let us go Richard
Rogers in 1930 having some liquor and
writing song let's go now already for
Richard Rogers was he thinking that he
was saying let us go
he knew he wrote it but when we say
let's go really we're just saying le TZ
let's go there's been a whole new
grammatical
which you can see called the hoard it is
but really it's a way of summoning let's
go if a linguist came down and listened
to us to speaking casually and never
looked at the page they'd hear as a
prefix go that's how did you often hear
it said still QT that's what I would say
to my daughter I would never say let
let's go and I might say let's go but
really it's kind of put your hood on
come on use your rice crackers alright
let's go that's it so so that's the
prefix where did the prefix come from
from two words let us perfectly ordinary
it's happening all the time or Walt Walt
now imagine if you made up a language
and you've come up with a word for
ambulating and then you want to put it
in the past and you think will become
corny to just say yes to but especially
if you meant an hour ago how you got to
put it in the past you certainly
wouldn't think of adding some little bit
of stuff to the end of the word you
might if you already spoke a language
that did that but if you can put
yourself in the mind of somebody who
still naming things out of the blue how
do you put it in the past you wouldn't
make up a suffix subject has happened by
accident walked started as walk did and
keep saying that over and over and
pretty soon you're saying Walt
so did starts out as an actual word and
then did become a suffix all our
prefixes and suffixes started as whole
words so language changes not only in
terms of words coming to mean new things
but some words grab onto other words and
they stopped being word at all it's a
fascinating process and so if English
were allowed to just move on with nobody
having any judgments there'd be new
grammar that we could practically hear
happen it so for example young people
using the quote ative all so she's all
I'm going to go to the store and he's
all no I want you to
some balloons we hear that and we think
well that's the youth butchering the
language but if the youth were allowed
to just keep going the way youth did to
make old English into Middle English
into modern English then I'm all said
again and again might become I'm all and
then you're all will become your bra and
he's all who become he zone English
would have a brand new irregular verb it
would be this weird new verb of saying
and we could be a language where we
could laugh at other people for not
knowing how to do our irregular verbs
would be just like all that stuff that
we master or don't make friends and
sense more also but it can't happen
because everybody keeps saying but I'm
all in you're all is bad grammatical
ization is happening all the time
beautiful now then there's sounds sounds
are always changing and linguists never
share with the general public how sounds
work because teaching it you're always
afraid people are going to be bored and
so in words on the move I thought
somebody needs to do a chapter about the
sounds so it doesn't get listy and
somehow keeps the reader moving on I
worked so hard on that chapter I'm told
that it's almost succeeds some of the
reviews already
if so the part about the sound but the
idea is to get across that the sounds
are not AEIOU
that has no meaning except that it's an
D thing to give to small people when
you're teaching them how to read that is
not anything like how our vowels work
and certainly not where they are in the
mouth so for example look at that there
and that column that you have on the
list that's the front of a head cut in
half if I meant for those of you who've
seen Breaking Bad what happened to frame
imagine the head cut in half
except he's looking the other direction
from that shot on the shelf and so it is
no
and his lips and so beet bait that those
are all said up front it doesn't feel
like it if you just say deep bay back
but then look at the column in the back
and say boot boat bot and notice that
it's all further back so all of this is
amount and so the back of the neck is
over on the right and the front of the
face is in the front that's where all
the vowels are it's the sounds of those
words not the barbaric way that we spell
it but if you know where all of those
sounds sit and that's what that chart is
meant to show then ways that people
pronounce things start to make a sense
that otherwise just feel like why do
they keep saying it like that and so for
example in California so something
that's been happening for I think about
25 years somebody says that but the
truth is if that Martian listened to
them they would think they were saying
that so somebody's saying a little bit
but really think of it somebody about 30
who grew up in LA they might say instead
of a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit now they're saying a
little bit we hear them saying a little
bit because we can read but really
they're saying a little bit a little bit
now in the same way that person if they
say that they're saying something a lot
more like that and so we made a bet we
made a bet and I sound like I'm
imitating a young girl but really I'm
just producing those kinds of vowels so
a bit of a bet would be a better bet a
bit of event hard of imitating that
person is to do those vowels
now notice that even if I don't do that
slight nasality it's a bit of a bet
that's what that person says every
second one of my students at Columbia
has those vowels now you can write about
it and you can hear it and you can think
well why do they do that but if you look
at the chart you can see that vowels
just are always moving around they are
like they're like bees in a hive and so
in any language it's not whether the
vowels are going to move its where
they're going to move
they never sit still so part of language
changes the vowels are always moving and
so bit is falling into that and then
because that is being moved out it goes
to that perfectly normal the sound all
is leaching out of the speech of
increasing numbers of Americans it makes
it harder to teach the international
phonetic alphabet every year and so for
example I'm 51 I was born in
Philadelphia for me caught and caught I
caught a fish you sleep on a cop are
different for increasing numbers of
Americans and it's becoming practically
it's it's become the majority is by some
counts you have cop and cuff as the same
sound so you sleep on a cop and then
yesterday you caught a fish that's
probably true of many people in this
room that's been happening for a while
there's no reason it's certainly not
cultural it's because vowels moved and
you can see how this would work bought
and then bought bought is slipping down
into the stock that up is it and so next
thing you know you caught a fish and
this change gets more entrenched every
year I used to tough students who had
what link was called a caught cost
murderer
well if you're having trouble hearing
all and you want to write words in
what's considered the IPA of mainstream
American English then what do you say
when a kitten crawls up your leg and
goes meow and it used to be that anybody
would say all and so there was the all
its at the point this actually happened
just this fall I told the class if
you're having trouble hearing all what
would you save a little kitten climbed
up here leg and set me out half of a
class that they would say ah because
they don't have all anymore it's
changing now easy to say what why that's
what because that's the sort of thing
that happens all the time
so each vowel has different places that
it might move you never know exactly
where it's going to happen but it's kind
of like a chess board that certain moves
that would
happen and in any language the vowels
are always just churning around in that
fashion even spelling makes more sense
I made a fist now you think about how
made is spelled ma de why why would it
be spelled that way it should be spelled
something like M easy like any normal
European language why is it spelled ma
dead
well it's spelt my death because that's
the way it was originally pronounced it
started out back there in box and then
it did a pit-stop in back and it went up
to date and so it started out with the
off sound move to the a sound and so ma
day became made and so spelling even
makes more sense if you understand sound
change these things are so deliciously
arbitrary I am I cannot stand those
small towns up in New England I hate to
say that but I know people find it very
quaint to go to the Berkshires and those
towns where everything is brown and
everything is clean I have never
understood it the only way I can get
anything out of those tiny places is to
go to the book store and you go in the
back and you find the interesting things
the last time I was in one of those
little towns I went to the bookstore and
I found this wonderful guide to speaking
American English from the mid 1880s and
it was absolutely bizarre what this
earnest man said were the proper ways to
pronounce things in 1887 and so these
are Edith Wharton's people we're not
talking about Chaucer we're talking
about if you read house of mirth this is
the way these people spoke age of
innocence they didn't talk like Michelle
Pfeiffer and Daniel day-lewis they
talked like this these are the sorts of
things that were being said here on this
ground granny mingott didn't live that
far from here so I made up this
paragraph but this is based on this
person's idea of how you're supposed to
say things in proper company one might
compensate for solidity by sampling and
juicy nectar in' or by about Tony
people were serious about that balcony
was considered really low class by about
Coney se and taken a melodrama that
would be better than making do with a
canine dense takabal dishonest person so
not canine that was very lowly canine
and then despicable imagine Daffy Duck
saying that you're despicable
okay not in death seqable dishonest
person seeking that is elite you certain
things must take precedence over others
my dear try being an on add no matter of
source these were the good pronunciation
well you know that just changed
another one is Buffett not Buffett that
was considered striving you're supposed
to call it Buffett so sounds are always
changing they're changing in a cuter way
than that too there's something called
the back shift nobody has ever called
exit until me I wanted to have that name
I'm trying to spread it around it's
called the back shift because you don't
want to hear what it's called in the
Linguistics journals but look at a verb
like rebel outlaw record now if you
rebelled then you're not a rebel you're
a rebel if you outlaw something you're
an outlaw if you record something you
make a record if you speak English you
know this subconsciously nobody talks
about it but you just do it without
thinking and what it means is that when
something becomes a thing then the
accent shifts backwards and it creates
all sorts of things that you don't think
about and so for example nowadays the
old movies and old TV shows are so
available you can hear how funny people
sounded because back ships hadn't
happened in the past Eddie Cantor um
about a quarter of this room will need
to know he was a very popular
vaudevillian and musical theater and
I'm movie sir in the first half of the
20th century he had a status he came off
kind of like a less creepy pee-wee
Herman and he was about as popular as
Jimmy Kimmel big deal so he had movies
and some people who are clinically
insane has seen all of them many times
and you hear him say funny things so at
one point at the end of one of his
movies in 1932 he says I learned it from
a Boy Scout and I thought what is a Boy
Scout why is it not a Boy Scout because
the scouts were new only since 1910 so
it starts out as oh well these are not
the Ranger Scouts these are the Boy
Scouts now it becomes an established
concept you start saying Boy Scout by
the time that was fully established
cancer was much older in another movie
he talks about eating a hot dog as a
post-doc dog because hot dogs were newer
Sunset Boulevard is a movie more people
have seen than anything Eddie Cantor did
in voiceover early on the movie is 1950
Holden talks of his character talks
about going to a supermarket and you
think no supermarket why didn't they do
a retake
what's a supermarket but when market was
the ordinary term the big weird ones
were called supermarket so look at the
supermarket supermarket only happened
because of the back ship there is a one
episode of the Dick Van Dyke Show
it's 1964 a woman comes on is about the
age of the century and she's talking
about well I was doing a crossword
puzzle and my husband said and I thought
what's a crossword puzzle it's a
crossword puzzle the New York Times
crossword puzzle but they only happened
in the 20s when she was a young woman
she would have learned it as oh let's go
do that thing in the paper the crossword
puzzle old habits die hard and there you
go or this is something you should just
find online it's not all these things in
black and white that seems so remote
Mary Tyler Moore is in college so that
means it's modern
and in an episode of 1972 they're having
something that they all call Chinese
food they're saying well you know it's
late I don't feel like cooking let's
have some Chinese food and it's not just
one of them because then Rhoda walks
down the steps and she took yeah let's
have some Chinese food and you think
what is Chinese food why's it like Marsh
and food and then you think to yourself
wait at 72 Chinese food is not default
yet we call it Chinese food but to them
it was still kind of a novelty that's
because of the back ship we have shifted
it backwards
certainly Mary Tyler Moore and Valerie
Harper say Chinese food now but back
then it was new and so because of this
sound change we get into the final kind
of change this is called compound in
linguistics I never liked that term so I
came up with a different but it starts
out with something really boring I
remember finding this one of the dullest
things I've ever heard when I was 12
English 6 which is that well the way
that some words are created is that two
words come together and they main one
and some people find that interesting in
itself and so there's a black board and
a black board is some plank that you
paint black that is the black board and
that's something very specific with
chalk it's not even black usually
anymore and where black board came from
was that black and board came together
and it became a black board God who
cares except there's the back shift and
so think about it oh you're going to
have to get a black board to go with
those pink boards as opposed to put it
up on the black board nobody would say
put it up on the black board same thing
a bird might be blue I'm Australian
whatever but then there's something
called a blue bird and you have the back
shift but still frankly you know that's
not something one we want to share
outside of one's home what gets
interesting is that they're the dumb
ones like those
four and Bluebird but really words come
from this and then you don't even know
so for example imagine yourself with no
writing you can tree you and you hear
about things like cupboards and
breakfast you don't think of a cupboard
as a cup board I don't know what a cup
board is I don't really know what
coverage is but I remember hearing a
word when I was younger and I didn't
think of it as a board that you put
cuffs on because you pronounce it
cupboard cuff and board are gone
breakfast
we know intellectually that it's about
breaking it fast but if you admit it you
didn't really know that so you were
about ten you have to read it it's
really just a word breakfast but still
you can see it in the spelling but then
there are other ones where it's not even
in the spelling and so you should go out
into the world Daisy
remember Downton Abbey Daisy where did
that name come from why she Daisy why is
the flower a daisy because it took days
I say days I over and over and over and
you're bored but you're also spending
Daisy so days on Daisy Daisy Daisy Daisy
a sheriff is a shire Reeve you're the
Reeve of the shire say that over and
over again in your loon share and so
those two words came together just like
blackboard came to mean black board and
so black board in the future might be
something like flowered and then it will
be interesting day p.m. Sarah's are that
way notice how originally I had puffy
that I thought that was unpleasant
changed it to sheriff but forgot to
change it here huh see what originally
housewife say that over and over again
and unfortunately it comes out as that
so then you have ones where you would
never know barn you would think that
barn was probably the first word ever
invented barn steam so unitary and large
no it was the barley Arne and Arne was a
place of sleep Arne was a dormitory a
guest arns of the hotel - barley Arne
was
you put your barley the word was
actually there there are bear on bond
but fun barn started out as two words
world started out as two words and so
weird and complicated that I'm not going
to explain but there was no ancient
proto-indo-european word werewolf or
something like that it was two words
where an L and they came together here
we are so word sex compounding creates
an awful lot of words when words come
together and they undergo the back shift
and after a while they blend together so
that you never knew that they were ever
two so this brings us to the end and it
means that it's not only literally that
we could learn to like but like and the
way people use it these things it's so
easy to hear it's trash when you listen
to liking you think well it's not
systematic and something's wrong with
people today for some reason today it
happened today not before you know
modernity is difficult and what we're
talking about is people using it like
this this is a guys about 15 I heard on
the subway a couple of years ago and I
kind of scratch down what he said so we
got there we thought we were going to
have the room to ourselves it turned out
that like a family had booked it already
so we're standing there and they were
like grandparents and like grandkids and
aunts and uncles all over the place
then he they all ran out of the training
and I thought well I was a strange
little sequence of the sentences and I
was trying to think of why it grabbed me
and first of all the whole situation he
was talking about didn't make sense it
had something to with a bar mitzvah or
something and I thought those were
beautiful lights because he was a very
confident kid he was not hesitation 'el
he did not have his head down he didn't
have bad posture he was an alpha male
and yet it was like every two seconds
and it's because if he really analyzed
the way people use logic they're using
it as a faith marker you can find
sexuality acknowledgement and
expectation this guy was making it clear
that he really meant what he was saying
he was making it clear that you
might expect that there wouldn't be
grandparents where the bar mitzvah was
going to take place for some reason but
there were and so what he means is again
another kind of really or this is like
the only way to make it work that's even
that's better than saying this is the
only way to make it work
boom lights has a certain grace that
certain politeness to it kind of like
let's take our pill now someone says but
they're not going to take it it makes it
gentler to pretend that you two are
going to take that horse pill well this
is like the only way to make it work so
I don't care about that slide like has
done many different things it's actually
quite beautiful and so there was a
dramatic word it was pronounced leaked
in a mint body of all so one addicted in
meaning like the Shakespeare word it
became a face marker it became grammar
lights became Lea
not to mention somebody saying she was
like blah blah blah its grammar it
changed and sound leak became like and
it communed with other words and so
alike like-minded all those things that
like did and yet we listen to life and
we all like him I think he he deserves
better
so there's a book about language change
I forget which one just published read
and at the end the office says maybe
some prefer their flowers press dry and
books they're those with affectionate
feeling towards the inflatable doll and
the courts surely though most of us seek
life language lives so my message is
simply that language could never not
change and the things that you hear and
think of as desecrations are exactly how
old English became Middle English and
Middle English became modern English one
of the oddest things in the world to
wrap your head around is that there's no
other way for language to change if you
don't think it was wrong that Latin
became French then you can't hate the
way people are using literally or that
somebody says
that or that people are using like in
brand-new ways because that's the only
way that a language becomes something
different and if it was okay in the past
then just in the logical sense it's hard
to defend the idea that the change
shouldn't happen now we worry that we're
not going to be able to communicate but
then again that problem has never
occurred in the history of any language
that any linguist or anthropologist has
ever encountered we'll always be able to
communicate and so you can think of the
language change is just a parade when
you hear new stuff you think wow that's
an interesting thing to happen to it
given that something was going to happen
to it you start wondering what it's
going to be next when certain people
started saying I literally can't even
about five years ago I remember thinking
that's cool that's that I like that I
wish I could say without sounding fake
where other people were writing little
pieces about it saying that it sounded
sub literate and hesitant and dull it's
just more fun to love that your language
will always change prints is a Polaroid
snapshot a word is not something that is
a word is something going on another way
of putting it is that words are always
on the move that's the name of the book
and I wrote it and it's about the
spectator sport of how and why language
changes thank you very much
[Applause]
that Shakespeare and how we use that
news in English when I write when I
reach a pyramid not new translations in
the value I don't need languages evolved
at different rates and if so why if
you're in a very remote area will the
language of all devolvement with a
language evolved less rapidly how does
that work I mean it's interesting you
mentioned Shakespeare and other
languages because that's another
argument because Shakespeare is
translated into relatively modern
versions of other languages very often a
European gets Shakespeare in a way that
we don't I saw Macbeth at them a few
years ago with with Patrick Stewart and
there were Russians behind me who were
happily in quoting it in Russian
including their children they got it in
a way that we get Tony Kushner whereas I
must admit even I was sitting there
thinking that's is hard and I have read
it in a few years and it wasn't because
I'm not poetic although I'm not it was
because the library this change - change
is ordinarily much faster than we're
used to and so if a language is not
written and very very few languages are
only about 200 languages are written in
any real way language isn't written it
just marches along and because people
don't think of it as frozen on the page
there's much less resistance to the
spoken language changing even if there's
some high register to values and
ceremonies or something like that but
the idea that it's this way and not that
way and I'm going to beat somebody on
the head for saying it that way less and
so some languages have been documented
to just turn upside down structurally
within a century once you've got print
print creates an illusion and I say that
if somebody who lives in print I love it
viscerally but language on the page is
an obstacle to perceiving linguistic
because you think that's it and that's
sitting still so that must be the way it
is when really language has always been
mostly spoken so English changes much
more slowly these days than it
ordinarily would
Beowulf to Shakespeare the languages on
those things are so different that they
barely deserve the same name Shakespeare
to hear I have to make the point that
the changes are subtle but they're more
pernicious than we might think but I
have to make the point because obviously
Shakespeare was using a language that
we're using so yeah we our brains are on
writing the way I put it in the book and
it's a wonderful thing in many ways but
it also makes you cranky about language
change and it's kind of a disease are
filled up I'm troubled by the common use
now of the word is by me since I visited
compensation using - yes I see is a yeah
yeah I'm 71 that was a word that was not
used at all over the course Felger word
and you would have been abolished as you
use that at all I'm wondering kind of if
you lament the change in that kind of
word becoming popularized and expanded
but I think now people by large do not
know they're saying of all guarantee and
obviously nothing can be done about it
but does that bother you and if you work
you referred to your daughter if your
daughter started using that word would
you correct her of the rich question
often our taboos evolve and so it used
to be that the big taboo was about
religion and so to say oh my god was
wrong there are still some people who
consider that to be unpardonably taking
the Lord's name in vain let's face it
for most people to horses out of the
burn then especially starting in the
1800s
the taboo was sex and
screeching and so you did not talk about
pissing and that has certainly changed
very much in the media in terms of
ordinary conversation and I would say
I'm 51 and so I'm beginning to not even
be able to pretend that I'm young I
think and get away with youngish and I'm
also fundamentally a rather starchy
person I will agree with you I don't
particularly like how free people are in
casual settings in jumping up and say
I'm going to go pee now I don't think
there's anything wrong with it it
doesn't fit my sensibilities when I was
in college a person was less likely to
say it not there I'm going to do it he
knew what they were doing but I'm going
to go pee and describe it I must admit
that to me it's must you talk about that
however nobody is going to stop and that
marks me as you know somebody who can't
jump so to speak but we do have taboos
so there's certain things that are not
said think about the words that I'm not
going to say because these fans here
those are really the taboo words now I
have made the argument that I am going
to say these damn hell [ __ ] and [ __ ] are
no longer profanity they're just salty
and I do put my money where my mouth is
in that my soon-to-be five-year-old
because frankly I'm not so star to that
I don't curse a lot at home my
five-year-old has picked up [ __ ] and as
makes sense
in 2016 the word for that for her she's
already picked up that if it refers to a
child it's poo but otherwise she doesn't
know the word feces she worn [ __ ] and so
actually a couple months ago we were
outside and there was something a dog
had done and of course there are all
these people around us and she with her
big Shirley Temple smile she said daddy
watch out for the [ __ ]
everybody heard and a part of me started
to say you don't say that in public and
then I really checked myself and I
thought you know what by the time she's
11 she's going to be saying it with her
friends all the time and that's only six
or seven years from now which is a
heartbeat and so I added dolly that was
very funny and that is a very real word
but try to only use it around me for a
while because there's some people such
as in your school who have and I told
her I said a lot of the parents in your
school have a certain idea which frankly
doesn't quite make sense that you're not
supposed to say that word until you're
11 or 12
she said why daddy and I said I'll
explain it to you in a few years I
didn't tell her not to say it because
frankly it's not profane however I know
many parents would disagree with me
about it but I there are words that I
would never want her to use if she had
erupted with the n-word or some other
word out there then I would have you
know covered her mouth and run into the
house
so we have our profanity but I don't
think it's about those bodily things
macular saying that pisses me off that's
where we hear it now newscasters said if
I kept using that using F as the word
that angers me or that frustrates oh
sure it's so common now and it just
disturbs me yeah no it doesn't it
doesn't mean urine anymore No
just like that sucks
it doesn't mean yeah you have to allow
it I'm sorry I um I'm not a least crazy
sure heads at first but I come from
language from a background more of like
data science or like understanding there
and and that for me kind of applies the
really when you hear work what you're
trying to disconnected to meaning and
there's a large distribution of
probabilities over worse that meaning to
take there's the most common use of the
word
but even individually a woollen isolated
works has multiple different meanings
and we don't already had to integral
word for board yeah and it's really when
in bring in context of a sentence that
it begins to matter than that meeting
and only movie begins bring in the
context of you're describing here and
and that we should think about words as
distributions of a probability of
meaning rather than rewards are
distributions or probabilities over
meaning and to the extent that that
seems like a cotton ball or kind of
something with a kind of a couette core
and then kind of a blur that thing moves
and so not only is it always larger than
we might think what a word means but it
moves along on the grid and that's what
words are but yeah word is nothing as
tidy as what the dictionary makes it
look like just thinking of get set and
put and those are easy examples but just
what any number of things mean and it
does get into the fact that we no longer
keep imply and infer separate it's
because of the nature of words and
meanings in the approximate way that
these things corresponding
I have a question about how do we
preserve language we're not going to
solve it from changing but I see it in
English that we translate things to more
modern ways many of language is Arabic
and I've gone through some very
extensive like traditional Arabic
training and so when I read the card
I'll be able to understand it slightly
even though it's very very old but I see
my little sister who hasn't gone through
the same training you just speaking the
words not fully understanding what they
mean but we don't have that process in
Arabic what they would change the old
text to new like to preserve the meaning
but with new words then how would
languages like that we don't have that
transition preserves those like ancient
texts for people who still speak the
language to still be able to extend it
that's very insensitive um if you're an
Arabic speaker you have the advantage
that because you often have to not only
be able to read but speak this language
that's preserved but then what you learn
at home as a child is something
different you're bilingual and then
whatever else you speak is the third and
so to be an Arabic speaking person if
you're Egyptian for example I don't
think you think of yourself as speaking
the Egyptian language and the Arabic
language it's all Arabic but it's two
things you speak Latin and Italian
that's a wonderful thing and it is
because of the position of the Quran and
the idea that the Quran isn't supposed
to change that's great frankly in the
typical situation my feeling and this is
my bias I feel that Shakespeare should
be adjusted I think it's absurd that
most opera is not sung in English in
this country some of them you can't
translate but most of them that you're
sitting there listening to Italian for
three and a half hours barbaric it needs
to be translated
and in this the same way I think that
they will know only if you're a scholar
and you're really interested in reading
Beowulf should you have to deal with
that Chaucer maybe you give it to people
in Middle English but I think really
will be more effective to translate it
and so yes these things should be
preserved some people have said that the
answer to the Shakespeare problem is to
train students in Shakespearean English
life is complex I think that we have
enough to do and so I believe that those
things should be preserved but usually
things should be done in the vernacular
call me Martin Luther that's my field
with no respect disrespect intended
towards the Arabic tradition even that
language changes and changes community
after episode on just this is for
courtesy do somebody over here because
there have been present
so anyway given that language changes
and it does so communally how do we
teach grammar to those individuals who
want to speak what they think of this as
properly you have to teach what's
considered the proper the proper
language and so my idea is not that we
ignore what's considered the standard
it's just that I would like us to hear
people not using the standard as using
something different rather than
deficient and so I remember knowing
somebody who dumped a guy partly because
she said he keeps making grammatical
errors and I thought oh no it's just
that he's he's a non-standard speaker
but no you have to know these things and
so talk about my daughter who's going to
hate watching this online 7:15 but for
example she has to know what the
standard is I wouldn't keep that away
from her we're talking about things like
saying fewer books instead of less books
but the idea is that if somebody says
less books you don't hear them as making
a mistake as if they went two plus two
equals five these things must be taught
and I'll even give you another one some
people say like too much and that
you know I be fake if I did not say that
there are young people who say like
about twice a sentence and for me that
fine if they're talking to their friends
I think it's wonderful
but if they're trying to sound
authoritative if they're trying to make
a point I've actually gotten to the
point where I have told some people
you've got to pull back on that in
public situations that have liked it or
not light is always going to sound
approximate that nothing I write will
change that and so yes there are
standards
I wish there weren't I'll definitely say
that but utopianism is silly
so yes standards must be trouble we have
to stop heating the way everybody sounds
when they're not being expended
estimates when I was a kid in the
fifties of Brownsville and later in the
projects and should say day I had black
friends as Puerto Rican friends ethnic
whites in Jerusalem and the D F word
never came up we never you know you
watch you get to mouth washed out with
soap we were told and nobody other no I
never heard it but then when I went into
when I three a few days into into basic
training when I was 19 suddenly I'm
talking we all had to speak to our
parents on the pay phone
they made us call our parents up when
you're older this is 68 early 68
suddenly this ball ed B of the word was
was F and my fault a de Guerre on the
phone until I was talking with mother I
said you have to stop you know he told
me what I was doing and I had to stop
and the figures I also recently heard
that a few about 10-15 years ago at the
in a civil war I thought the F word
wasn't used but it was used as a sexual
sexual term but I'm just remembering it
you know what when anything was going
Bearden when there was stretched out or
angry what would he say and it was a Shi
T I don't know I have no idea you mean
what did John Wilkes Booth's say
well when all when they were getting
well whether you was getting the
Confederates or the union's only the
other one but you know what about to get
over well what would it smell what would
you what would they say you know it's a
very interesting question and it shows
you what it's like when you have a
difference that comes back to the Arabic
point actually between formal speech and
casual speech that's faster than what
we're used to so we think that those
Civil War soldiers all talk like
Shakespeare because anybody could write
that way even after eighth grade those
letters are great they didn't talk that
way but we don't know exactly how they
talk because they couldn't be recorded
you get little hints and so for example
Washington Roebling was working not on
the Brooklyn Bridge but I think on the
eve bridge in st. Louis and he writes a
letter to his wife that the men were
erupting in a great many ODEs today you
know there was one but it means that the
men didn't found the way he wrote to his
wife but you can only know so much slime
dictionaries only tell you so much
carnation was something that a lot of
people said eternal damnation comes down
to tarnation which then becomes calm
then becomes Donner darns not a word
that happened to the combination there
was another one of those so that's one
I'm pretty sure that they were not
hauling off and yelling [ __ ] there is no
evidence of that it was used in a more
pristine sense it's hard to know those
Matthew breed soldiers what did they say
when somebody stepped on their toe or
shot them and you know they're just
they're very quiet I listened to an
early on recording Benjamin Harrison the
23rd president he had no features there
was nothing about him he had no trace
but he did make it recorded and you can
hear him talking but he never says [ __ ]
so it's just hard to say
I don't hate you I'm going to ask about
literally actually um so no problem with
continence because they resolve
themselves in context but I think and
literally does also sometimes like if I
say my head literally exploded everyone
know that that didn't happen because
very you are fine but if I say tefillin
tomorrow I went to this talk and I had
to wait on line they were like a hundred
people there were literally a hundred
people on line they don't know that I
mean that they were actually a hundred
people when they hand in hand was part
of three people were so everything is
big when they may even think that there
were more than hundred so happy note is
it wrong to try to hold the line
somewhere other than like possible
futilities I mean just just so that we
can actually hear now in real time not
to go through the centuries understand
each other you desire to be understood
and known to an extent that maybe I
don't mean maybe I'm aloof or something
if somebody says there were literally
hundred people I assume they mean that
it was a big bunch of people that it
wasn't is twenty but it may have been 52
and that's just then I'm done but you
really want it to end
I actually I respect that and so you
just you you you are probably just more
of a connector then I I I respect it but
there is the first for the in-person
Valley literally a hundred yeah I just
don't care but I understand that you can
I am
I'm owning the loss of certain beauty in
our vocabulary
and find it sometimes I have to
translate my own sentences when I'm
speaking can you say anything about the
SAT words and where they're going or
where they've gone the SAT you know the
the vocabulary words of yesteryear you
know here's soothe pristine propecia I
could go on egregious egregious a
personal favorites yeah expiate
expatiate XP tree XP a person that's
patriot a person expatiate is to go on
too long that was always my favorite
it's funny you ask that I had a rather
unpleasant session with some students a
few weeks ago where we read a passage of
mine from a book I wrote good long time
ago now where I said that there was
something to teaching students some of
those words that you might not get from
ordinary conversation because it would
make it easier to read advanced tests
and I had a couple of those students who
were deeply offended by the notion that
students would be subjected to that
especially ones who were
socioeconomically disadvantaged and I
very much take their point however I
also think that it's part of being an
English speaker to often be wary of
words like those and so for example if
we heard about Italians cherishing the
outer layers of their vocabulary we
think on well of course and I don't
imagine I'm not deeply immersed in
Italian culture because I'm not familiar
with it at all
you don't imagine there being too much
pushback about it there's a sense that
there's our language I don't imagine
Russians saying no we don't want to know
Pushkin's words we're just going to use
our kitchen sink words but
it's part of being American to have that
call it Democratic feeling may be
individualistic feeling that expatiates
is not necessary so I'm on the fence I
mean on the one hand you can be very
articulate with a small vocabulary but
on the other hand within limits there
are some words in the dictionary they're
kind of stupid so for example ruthless
well there's a word root it know there's
that's that shouldn't be and their roots
supposedly means mercy but yeah I get it
I get it
the fun words yeah there are words
however we should also learn to hear
articulate us in vulgar speech because
people can be so very articulate with a
small vocabulary a lot of it is how you
put the words together I look two minds
thank you I just wanted to you had
mentioned like when you your daughter
use the word Shi T you didn't go up for
anything but you try to explain to her
context or appropriate times when she
could use the word and you said if you
ever heard or so the in words would
immediately correct or and cover a mouth
and thank you for that because me
personally I feel like I'm in a
painfully losing battle on that one and
you even have some highly educated I
guess you might call them intellectuals
make the argument that it's a way of
disempowering the word or taking away
the stick and I reject that but what I
want to hear is your argument to push
back against the argument that is
disempowering or it's turning into
something positive because I think it's
cordoning the society and really you
know a very negative thing I seek to say
that I'm not quite with you on that oh I
take your point if that word is used as
a slur then that's our said boot and
there
if that word is being used out there now
by and it's not so Blackmon anyone else
white guys as soon as our backs are
turned are using it with each other if
they are using it to mean buddy okay one
I don't think we can stop it - and I'm
not trying to be cute and saying this
word meanings change that word has
become - there's the slur but then
there's this word buddy because that
kind of word in many languages often
comes to mean buddy
and so in Russian the word for peasant
is used in that way there's a list of
examples now talk about my daughter
sorry
Dahlia this is one night talking about
her what's coming is first at some point
she's going to learn about the slur and
that's going to be easy don't say it to
stop and if anybody else says it walk
away but then she's going to ask one day
daddy how come I hear boys walking down
the street how come they can do it and
I'm not going to tell her they shouldn't
do it either because they only mean
buddy and you can't stop it and it's
subtle
[ __ ] [ __ ] did the sound change also
so now especially because no offense
that utopianism you know how people use
that word we can't fix it go to Bushwick
you're not going to stop anybody from
using it and so I hear it as different
and I feel sorry for the white guys who
has grown up listening to rap and they
think they can use it because they
really do mean buddy
I see where they're coming from but then
they have some people telling them that
when they do is they're using the word
that volcon or use that must really eat
tough for them so now what they do is
they do it when nobody can hear so for
example my office if the door is closed
I've heard neither Columbia students
walking by doing it they don't
in there they would never do it if my
door the world and this is tough stuff
not to slur but the word for buddy seems
like it's just permanent Michael Eric
Dyson once told me he uses it respectful
if he uses it then I think it's here to
stay
you deserve even as long but interesting
group of people here appreciate
participating in his conversation and
pre speaking so thank you and I
certainly got to your question you know
the triangle thing that you had look
back with the words I mean it is
Pascal's triangle essentially when we're
talking about like the random random
distribution and kind of bishops on both
sides and it's much more dimensional
than that how does it vary in maguro
letís because of resonance because
everything has a random distribution so
we find Patterson I'm kind of curious to
hear your song Daleks universes has a
lot of kinda science
and particularly everybody here like the
reason why you know because it's just
like in that contact life we're not
talking people that's why they say like
I'm really excited about this remember
they said about this you know like if
we're talking someone would be like Oh
what do you mean by you know literally
on your people or like you said I don't
really care so they continue with the
conversation so it's really like you
know multiple events collide into an
accident right and then we look back
it'll be called an appointment but then
we ask you that question is most likely
going to happen that's kind of percent
could happen to 30 happen question I get
your point you to come up and down but I
just I'm curious just like what do you
think about kind of the complex systems
that is language um and you said earlier
that like you know there's never going
to be a case where someone doesn't
understand what a person but in the
collection like it's just like we
imagine Americans we're speaking you
know very different version dialects
dialectical of the use of man's English
of whatever is so I'm 30 mm I um I'm
going to leave the part about
coincidence because that's very
interesting that that's a side by
conception but what you're talking about
is alarming in terms of how linguists
are trained to see language because
there's an idealization which is that
we're making stations and being heard
that is so little of what speech is you
say things for reasons you say things to
make people do things you say things
that skirt along the edges of what you
actually think you your words like use
words like totally in ways that have to
do with mutual thought patterns rather
than anything that you're stating all by
yourself
language philosophy teaches us that our
conception of language as being about
sentences that are right or wrong on a
piece of paper is even more
scientifically erroneous than I even
begun to get it I think that if
linguistics started all over again it
would be a field I might not be in
because what we're doing when we speak
is so much more than putting forth an
entity and then predicate about it
however when I say that we always
understand each other of course not on
the individual level so for example with
Trump quite often we listen to him as if
he were making statesman like
pronouncements thinking about how they
would be heard and their larger
implications when really for reasons
sociological and psychological and
frankly I think psychometric he doesn't
mean them that way he says a lot of
these things and you could say that he's
just biessing he's improvising he's
being sarcastic he's exploring and then
reporters listen to him as if this was
Obama saying something and we're trying
to get used to what Trump means by
language yes there's a great deal of
misunderstanding on that level what I
meant was that language never breaks
down to the point that we really can't
even pretend to know what one another
are saying my can it feel like it but
yeah yes my our children is built that
body we will see because the original
Hebrew term was young so being the REE
REE challenge and that is computed by
hand are not wrong to the ocean
I should write one so so what it's like
the whole bit with the camel going
through the needle and so many other
things
there's nothing odder than finding out
what the EBU Bible actually said you
know first you know there's the
Septuagint and then that messes it up
some and then when you get all the other
translations is it's it's enlarged
inning to know how distorted our view of
these things are which is why I believe
in translations for example I mean now
that I've been salted Arabs I'm going to
insult Orthodox Jews in saying that the
idea of studying Talmud without thinking
about exactly what the translation would
be in dealing with all of these things
I've always thought no no really it
should be directly translated into
today's vernacular there's a great deal
of that I wish that vernacular
translation were more common and yet
we're just stuck with what we've got
ancient documents you can't live by them
or if you do translate them into the
language that you have and if you
discover mistakes
fixa don't just allow them to fit in
modern versions offense but I'm not
running the world so that's where we are
and you think they're a little
correlation between I need some current
relationship between language and
culture I find that even though English
is not my first language when I listen
to the shape you state reading of you
the clarity of you the beauty but for
nowadays young people have enough energy
to make a top 50 Tendai we can sell
right I cannot really it is no clarity
no beauty whatever make sense so it's a
recently I read and marketing that money
both running for governor because of the
election where they've threatened a
whole our coin there's no more like
nasus anything any word is rated for
meaningful for your own saying is a lot
beautiful ugly if it was really intense
and eighty seven eight by maxing run
compounded but the such a beauty it's
about part of it I've been so nervous
first I want to correct myself about the
Talmud and say I am vastly on this love
today I think it's actually wonderful
for it to be engaged in the original in
the way that people do because at least
you do know what it's saying that's what
I meant to say on in terms of your
question what is your original language
Liz Lemon know your original language
okay Mandarin okay I think that on in
any language the way it's used
colloquially
and modern Lee is going to be quite
different from what's done on the page
and that's certainly true with the
Mandarin Chinese I'm sure you're
familiar with the difference between
what you can read and then what people
say
Mandarin is difficult for linguists
because you'll put a sentence on the
board and if there are Chinese speakers
in class people are a hard time agreeing
what is actually a proper sentence
because people have very different
senses of what's real as opposed to
what's on the
age how far you can get away from so I
think you're reading things in older
English and you're reading things on the
patient you're reading Mark Twain and
then you're hearing what's going on now
Mark Twain would have had the same
experience there was the way he wrote
and then there was a way people spoke
around him and so we today feel like
something different is going on because
people didn't write the way they spoke
as much in the past and there was no way
to record how people spoke so you just
get little incident if you see a silent
film of people walking down the street
they're walking in front of the Flatiron
Building you can see it the women's
dresses are going up it's at the point
where you can watch clear well-preserved
film of people a hundred one hundred and
ten years ago now how did they talk they
did not talk the way the magazines and
the newspapers depicted English but we
can't hear them then movies get sound
but the sound is bad and everybody is
reading from scripts and so they drop in
a little slang but we still don't know
how those people sounded Fitzgerald
writes novels where he gets in a little
bit of it but still Fitzgerald is a
formalist and so we still don't know how
those people at the party in Great
Gatsby talked it's tough today we know
how everybody talks and it's recorded so
the past only seems cleaner in that way
it was on people have always spoken met
feet when they speak casually that this
is human being as mandarin is spoken
outside of the page or or television for
me
I'm trying unsuccessfully because I
think of AIDS Pasteur to teach myself
Mandarin and I'm finding that one of the
difficulties is that there's such a
difference between what's on the page
and then when I read about as how people
actually fought their blogs and things
and I think good lord this is
practically a different language and the
standard one is already no offence on
what
and so these things are just the way
life goes I want to congratulate your
academic so shrug over coffee being
brought it down thank team on the side
of this I have real difficulty with
sight of technical as far as the history
separate language and family and
communicator and therefore result is
very bad understand exactly dangerous is
there any advice you would give is
unrealistic to say everyone should be
trained to define this as I can
understand what I say but how do we get
bridge the gap between the technical
language that people need to do to do
their job and the communication in
society that needs to understand what
we're talking about
well isn't that easier today with the
internet and social media in that you
can blog or you can write things that
are written for the general public to
understand or is that not what you mean
I take this back now I mean everybody
has the wrong time like create your own
time neutrinos
now there's really no factories I hate
well that's a whole different issue
identifying actual truth and dealing
with the fact that it's so elusive to
actually identify what anybody would
think of its truth if you think through
the layers of it but I think it's
inevitable that any field is going to
have jargon I think it is not inevitable
that in any field impenetrable sentence
structure is used and so in certain
worlds that were familiar with in the
humanities there's a way of writing that
has become a custom I don't think it's
deliberate I don't think that people are
being obscure insist our anything like
that but the way many literature
scholars write is impenetrable to the
outside world just because of drift
I think that's changed but for science
you need jargon I would say linguistics
is written in a jargon that's intended
to pull to outsiders to what I'm talking
about is diachronic theory and the way
this would be put in the flagship
journal whole things I've talked about
is deadly dull and loaded with a jargon
that you would think was deliberate but
linguist me after a while you forget how
impenetrable it is so I consider myself
to be doing my job by taking it and
trying to communicate what I think of as
the good parts in relatively ordinary
language but that doesn't work for all
sciences I mean it's clear that higher
math that simply can't be done
I've tried with physics and I've
realized there's a point beyond which
only physicists can understand and I can
we have an approximate understanding
which I've never actually read him know
as getting that sort of thing girl yeah
heaven her defend my person and I think
you so much bro talk and then her
brother for short rations
I heard about you mission international
phonetic alphabet and wait thought and
waste comp remember under heard about
this when freedom
yes - my medication if you take play
Pygmalion by soul who would you say who
you think be healings and the little in
2016 America and motivation is about
texting social media how possible to
Twitter and texting influence things
language and an by at the time and they
just they they the invariance of the
ground or the future of narrative
English in eight years the period some
Donald Trump is gonna have no influence
on English
social media has not influenced the way
we speak in any appreciable way because
social media is writing social media
have affected writing in that it's a
kind of writing that's more like speech
on Henry Higgins does not exist and as
wonderful a character is as he is I get
the feeling I'm never going to be
allowed to play that role for some
reason but he is an interesting
character but no linguist would ever
have prescriptive views as we call it
like that he wouldn't look down on Eliza
he would be taking down what she said in
the international phonetic alphabet
Henry sweet is the model for that
character was apparently a character but
you'll be taking it down and thinking
about how interesting her cockney
speeches in terms of its difference from
what became called received
pronunciation there is I know one
linguist who you could say is someone
who's a stickler for standard language
rules and seems to recoil slightly at
the idea of the breaking of those rules
even he intellectually though
understands that there's no such things
as broken language and he's a character
and has gotten in trouble for some
socio-politically odd statements I only
know one person like that and no
linguist would be like Henry Higgins is
a is a international phonetic alphabet
what a way to talk I mean how are you
know about it that they exist well the
international phonetic alphabet is used
by all linguists because spelling
systems are it is for the idea is to
actually transcribe what sounds actually
are instead of say the approximation
that I used in the vowel chart here so
it's one of the basics of linguist
training to be able to transcribe things
in that alphabet and in languages that
are new often you come up with an or
the graphical system that approximates
it because in many ways it's better than
any other system you will come up with
although to write a language completely
phonetically is often awkward for
various reasons but it Liz
so what Henry Higgins is depicted as
doing is part of the linguist toolkit it
doesn't translate well to the general
public probably because people are used
to that related but different version of
it is used in many dictionaries and it's
ugly its aesthetically unpleasant you
get used to seeing our words spell the
way they are for better for worse mostly
worse and so the IPA doesn't translate
well for example I do not mention it
except in a footnote in words on the
move but any linguist has to use it it's
it's our it's our alphabet thank you one
presentation question you obviously City
tremendous underfunded and are you see
the same thing happen with of the
languages evolving with the speech
mentioned Hebrew Hebrew the site does
that change in enunciation and the time
goes by it's moving along Hebrews moving
along and it's not just the
pronunciation it's new kinds of grammar
enunciation always because vowel active
moved when people talk about the
difference between Ashkenazi and
Sephardic pronunciation all of that is
because you would expect that different
people speaking the language in
different places would have their bowels
move in different ways there is no
language that's been still it couldn't
because people are always hearing things
a little bit differently so caught
caught you can't stop it so it's
interesting which means that any
language is gradually pulling away from
its writing system unless the writing
system keeps up with it which it
never does so that's one of the awkward
parts of being a modern human being that
you're going to learn to write something
that you don't quite speak it's
unfortunate some people have to deal
with it much less than others we and the
French and the Danes have a major burden
for after there are a lot of young
people use the word axe instead of ask
and they're told of death pain currents
like in the school systems and it was an
example of of non-standard dialects
anything that that word one becomes
standard usage you know
asses on another one of those exceptions
like light and so axe in itself is neat
it comes from an old English form
accion and it just happens there were
various words where they toppled the
Queen's cook and cook and so a mask used
to be a max a fish used to be a Fisk
which was a six axe happened to be one
that became asked that happened to
settlin as the word used by a certain
group of English speakers who happened
because of geography and happenstance to
be the people whose English became the
standard and so all of sudden axe
sounded low-rent and asked sounded
proper whereas for many people before
that it sounded odd so the reason black
people and many southern white people
say axe is because there have always
been people in England who still say axe
and a lot of those people were the ones
who were sent across the ocean to work
in hot streams America so for example if
you're going to leave England it's
probably not going to be the people who
talk like Downton Abbey they get to stay
home it's going to be the vernacular
speakers and so a lot of slaves for
example learning the language alongside
people saying ax and so today you have
the easing in the face paradigm so many
black speakers and say acts just like
anybody else but when you relax you say
ax unfortunately that one sticks out for
American English speakers in particular
for blacks features in particulars the
first thing that black people will
mention
like angles with ax and that's not going
to change especially because asking can
be thought of as a rather formal
activity so when company ears acts it
especially sticks out because ask seems
to involve a certain ceremony and then
here comes this vernacular form I wish
people didn't hear acts that way but I
don't think it can change so that I
would tell people that's one that you
should not use in a formal context but
at the two-way street I had a if I made
a white woman asking me very nicely
why does my black boss say acts at the
office and I told her well you know if
you're having a good time at the office
if you have some sort of casual
relationship with the boss what's wrong
with in saying acts while you're talking
about what happened downstairs yesterday
but I said I hope he doesn't say it in
board meetings and things like that
acts is unfortunate it's like like
people who say like every two seconds
not thinking about it it's a hard habit
to break
acts is like that but yeah that's the
one thing in black English where I say
folks sorry you know America is not
going to get used to that one and so
life is tough and you've got your
questions and for coming tonight
thank you
thank you
Oh